800,000 federal workers could miss their
first paychecks of the new year this
week the partial government shutdown is
now 10 days old and President Trump says
it won't end unless Democrats agree to
fund his border wall the Democrats say
no the Environmental Protection Agency
began furloughing its nearly 14,000
employees over the weekend chip Reid is
at the White House chip no doubt not the
way anyone wanted to start the new year
good morning to you know you've got that
right now Senator Lindsey Graham says
the president is open to some kind of a
deal but that deal would have to include
money for the border wall and that of
course is a non-starter for Democrats
the president is telling us what he
wants and he's willing to do some things
to get what he wants South Carolina
Senator Lindsey Graham came out of a two
hour lunch with President Trump Sunday
hopeful for a breakthrough Graham is
encouraging mr. Trump to negotiate with
Democrats by proposing to grant work
permits to children of undocumented
immigrants in exchange for over five
billion dollars for his border wall he's
very open-minded about combining wall
funding with other things to make it a
win-win for the country on Face the
Nation Democratic senator Jon Tester
said that President Trump backed away
from a similar deal in the past oh I
think we've been here before I was I was
in the room when the president said if
Congress passes something I'm going to
sign it and then he moved back away from
that we need some predictability
this comes as president Trump is
reversing this pledge to Senate Minority
Leader Chuck Schumer made earlier this
month I will be the one to shut it down
I'm not gonna blame you for instead he's
now referring to the stalemate as the
Schumer shutdown he's also blaming
Democrats for the deaths of two migrant
children in federal custody at the
border earlier this month Republican
Senator Richard Shelby whether it's the
president
tweeting and blaming somebodyís blaming
the Democrats or whether it's the
Democrats blaming the president it
brought us to the impasse that we are
today meanwhile hanging in the balance
more than 800,000 federal workers were
working without pay and others who've
been furloughed like Raekwon snyder who
don't know when they'll be paid next I
actually started donating some
some blood plasma we get to help people
of course but for the first five
donations to give you fifty bucks
whatever I have to do to put food on the
table and keep a roof over that's what
I'm going to do a spokesman for Senate
Democratic leader Chuck Schumer said in
a statement the White House doesn't know
what they want when it comes to border
security and over on the house side the
political landscape is about to change
in a big way when Nancy Pelosi becomes
Speaker of the House in just three days
Michelle
hmm the end in sight we're looking for a
chip thank you